hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Bohar f yeah that's a
pretty high rated guy I think there's no
info now i think is 2600 feeding so
let's see what he plays against my Benko
the most principled line has will be a
memorization job of course I've done all
this for the repertoire but I still
confuse the lines a little bit so I am
this is kind of kind of clear but okay
in that line okay I think this is right
but I told don't quite remember from
here can you just play like normal stuff
oh I think I think I actually take em
play Queen 86 I think I play with Queen
a six-year nights you forever how do i
play against nights you for I don't
remember um e6 I think it's esox
actually i think is success right but in
blitz I have trouble really remembering
my own up with suggestions sometimes I
think it's e6
and now maybe rupee 8 and are the edges
i think i just take right i think i just
take andrew create probably now okay so
the thing is i want to go d 697 but
there is Bishop to f4 this is it could
be an issue but it doesn't necessarily
have to be I mean like d6 beach before
97b should be 69 b6 is an issue for him
I think 96 maybe you can go nitey
five-foot other than take T 3 and T 5
okay so that should work actually so
okay just covers that yeah Bishop f8 is
not a dream move here really not night
h5 Bishop takes Knight b6 you have to
play really actively cannot some play
passive moves in the bank oh add this
term not it's not a usual policy you
should be fate I don't want to play nine
inch Knight takes bishop d 6 9 p-6 i
don't i don't know i have to recheck
this line again it's difficult i mean
even either me i'm having
have compiled this repertoire for chess
table but it's a there are lots of lines
and it's not not that straightforward
there are there are different approaches
quite often and I simply don't remember
all of the lines at least then when it
comes to when it comes to blitz chess I
sometimes struggle you have a little bit
of time I can remember everything but
it's not so easy in a blitz game so
let's see here I'm two points down but
still reasonably active now the deponent
is a big problem of course yeah III is a
good move this one came
didn't really think so much about this
but it's it's okay of course yeah at the
end he's got the deep own wants to play
with 94 him and he takes my room
now that that's losing I'd simply I
simply didn't remember my theory here
and it is some it is pretty crucial yeah
one thing that I have on my list to do
is actually to lock into an two chasa
ball and basically learn my own my own
stuff it's a it's really one thing to
have written and analyzed everything but
then to make sure that you have it all
in your memory is a different kind of
animal you really have to time Marnie
have to invest a bit of time to do that
I can't some kind of hanging in the air
but it's itself course losing yeah it's
also it's two parts it's the thing I
mean just that just the deep on would
probably lose as well but with the ape
on the deep on you sometimes can stop
because the king is so close but it's
quite difficult if it's some two pawns
okay here night is six is a little bit
annoying the pin here on the
fourth-ranked
let's see okay this one okay five is not
not a real threat
yeah thinking Knight a5 maybe would do
something with it doesn't it Knight b6
now as I had the threat in the line that
you played with 92 isn't actually all
that dangerous but as i said i just have
forgotten ok 9 a-5 check the larger
series button what to what to exactly do
again sir I'm fairly certain that this
is okay and I'm also quite positive
about e-cigs it's something that I
should check maybe let me let me check
that right away and see and see what it
is I'm back in a second ok so I have
checked what I have to do here and then
did have forgotten my recommendation and
he black should go d6 and the ideas item
yeah white will probably castle now and
now it's interesting idea night f27
which is pretty that's not very typical
to move the f noida sem but it makes
perfect sense here as there's a direct
attack on c3 and black sometimes just
gives up that Bishop if he gets the ball
back and potentially even get the a porn
yeah this is this is ok for black it's
not that easy for y2 to play this
position the computer actually suggest
this move which well it is a sign that
this is probably a decent position for
black Miami idea was then to play with
night should be six and the later
strategy is to play c4 at the right
moment and play the night over to c5
it's a very fairly typical play for the
bank
it's for me it's a bit tricky to
remember in this repertoire and it's
probably the same for them for four and
any other player learning the Bangko is
that in this modern interpretation of
the bank or wear black it's not moving
those pawns early you sometimes have
this option to play these six without d6
and this is often good but not every
time and it's something that I you
really have to master I mean I've looked
at it and I've found good solutions but
you still have to remember it and then
it's something as i said i have to
basically learn my own repertoire again
to UM you had to be totally sure what
happens and in any any circumstance so I
mean this is probably this is not
terribly bad it's just that probably the
other option is a lot better so I tried
this and yeah the thing is I have to go
d 6 cm and if Bishop f4 97 that this was
technically I think ok Knight b6 now
should be good yeah something they
cannot take it it is threatened and
there is an indirect attack on this so
here I'm very okay but he played the
strong move route 81 and now I don't
really have something good I think this
is relatively speaking of the best and
let's computer agrees and now the comp
wants to play 97 you are giving wide a
clear advantage it's two pawns and
against two pawns is difficult to yeah
with with two points down it's difficult
nanti defeated played that well
defending is the wrong word but like
yeah he kept my my mother's the
initiative here and shaky nicely yeah
okay I'm all still kind of hanging
hanging in here but
it is it is losing maybe there was some
some shots around here I don't know the
engine doesn't doesn't find anything
yeah it felt um like you did a good job
down yeah there's nothing much to say
yeah this is a case where it's all about
being precise in the opening so I have
to remember that here the six is correct
this is really an one of the few
situations in that in the bank over this
modern banco the you can screw it up
totally if you don't really know on
which white continuation to play e66 a
combination yeah and I've made a mistake
I left after I've made a similar mistake
in an earlier game it's something that I
really have to yeah LuAnn better even
though I've I've looked at it all for
the repertoire you still have to refresh
your memory ok guys thanks for watching